[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler free
review of the new a24 horror film
men
this is directed and written by alex
garland now i have a very complicated
relationship with alex garland because
ex machina is one of my favorite films
of all time i mean i remember the first
time i watched the film and falling in
love immediately i've watched it so many
times it truly is a masterpiece in my
eyes now i'm in this boat though when
annihilation came out i was so hyped
because i loved the first film he made i
was very disappointed with annihilation
i still thought it was okay i didn't
hate it but disappointed and then i
attributed okay maybe there's a point
too because maybe he was trapped by
jumping into a movie that's based off a
book so it's limiting him from what he
can do that's how i want to look at it
put that angle to just make me still
have faith in him right then devs came
out the show that i reviewed on hulu and
that was a disappointment to me it had
its moments but it was okay like
annihilation so then in my head i'm like
okay maybe i'm a little worried about
what alex garland is really capable of
is he in my eyes a one-hit wonder when
the trailer for men came out i was very
intrigued especially because he was
leaning more horror now and i was like
okay let's see what he can do he's got
two strong actors and jesse buckley and
rory kinnear here and i
hate to say this but
i absolutely did not like this film and
it felt
like where i started my relationship
with alex garland was here with his
films and then it was here down a little
here with devs and then now it's here
like this was just not a good film to me
and
i was so shocked how much i wanted this
movie to end multiple times and how much
i feel like i just
was not enjoying this in any shape or
form and it's strange because you have
such a good performance from jesse
buckley here rory kinnear is very good
he gets the job done there's still way
more of jesse buckley she has a lot to
carry here and she totally kills it
she's a great actress but
my god this stuff she was working with
here i did not feel it it's one of those
movies that
about 20 minutes in
when you start yours what's happening
you're either with it or you're not and
i was not with this i mean i was like
nope this is silly to me i'm not even
like
going into this where
i can't spoil stuff so in my spoiler
review you'll see it comes out when the
movie comes out i'll release that i'll
go into detail about things that i
thought was like one plot hole that was
driving me insane that was so
distracting and two why this felt more
silly to me than the horror feelings and
the disturbing feelings i should have
been feeling right where when you make
something that's you're swinging for the
fences which i appreciate like alex
caron swings through the fences a lot
like m knight in that sense where they
swing sometimes they hit it's awesome
and sometimes you can swing for the
fences and completely whiff and i feel
like he whiffed here like you could see
he was going for it and i respect that
i'll give him props for that i'm happy
he did that but to me it was a complete
whiff oh my god like if that line of
where something is you know really
creative different and has these horror
elements to it you
can cross a line though where it gets
just outright ridiculous and this was
outright ridiculous to me
and it's interesting because when i was
watching it i'm like i've had similar
feelings
watching something like this before and
it was making me so angry and i was like
oh i know what made me this angry was
jordan peele's twilight zone this felt
exactly like
an episode of that twilight zone reboot
where
it was not well done it was silly and it
also was pandering and what i mean by
pandering is that it's so literal and
what it's saying is something that
it's doing it in a way that's not in
like a way that's really
showing you and making you like oh wow
and like sucking you into that message
it's more just like telling you and then
showing you crazy body horror and
there's a lot of
flashback scenes which he loves to do in
all his work and you're gonna see an
opening flashback scene and you can kind
of i mean you really can figure out the
whole flashback story from the first
scene he puts enough in there you know
what's happening right away so when
you're getting more of them throughout
the film it's not adding anything and
this is what frustrated me a lot and
then everything that happens with rory
kinnear again i was just like what the
hell is this and if you like body horror
here's a positive the body horror was
awesome right it's gruesome body horror
and at the same time it's really silly
though like it looks sick but it's silly
and there's some cgi they put in there
again i can't spoil what character it is
but i was like oh give me a break like
maybe i'm being such a snoot here and i
should award turtleneck sweater to the
screening but
i i wanted to walk out but i didn't i
watched the whole thing
and i'll give it points for cool body
horror and great acting but
i just thought there was not a good
story to be had i thought that the
placement of the flashbacks didn't serve
much because you can figure it out from
the first flashback and that you just
kind of sit there and are like
how long does this take to think of like
was this done as a just a concept that
wasn't flushed out like what is this
what is this a movie like this didn't
even feel like a movie to me so
i'm really just pissed off about it i'm
giving it a 4.9 but i usually love a24
and what they do but this to me is a
movie that you're seeing a lot of
critics actually like this and this is
what happens a lot a 24 films or but i'm
usually on the side the critics when you
see on ron tomatoes like the critics
give it a high score and the audience
scores like rotten right that happens a
lot with a24 they're divisive they're
polarizing i am usually on that side of
the critics where i like all of them
most of them right
i will promise you that because this
one's getting good reviews this might be
the first day 24 one where i'm gonna be
on that side with the audience and i i
am convinced that this audiences mostly
will hate this film certain people are
gonna love it but i think i'll i mean
with the critics that i'm seeing right
now no one's touching on like no i think
people are going to walk out and hate
this freaking movie like it is to me
just bad and
i don't want to say that i i want it to
be good it had the pieces to be good but
this is how i felt watching it these are
my feelings maybe i'll like it better on
a second watch unfortunately that's the
news i bring you but
let me know if you're planning to see
this if you're excited to see this if i
just ruined that feeling for you i'm
sorry but let me know let me know your
thoughts on those other films as well
alex garland i'd love to hear your
thoughts on that and please subscribe to
notice my spoiler review that's coming
out so you i can kind of justify a
little more what i'm talking about and
i'll see you next time